jean charles de castelbajac
[Applaudissements]
jean-charles je ne parlerais ce soir de
votre collection printemps-été 2015 une
collection qui a beaucoup choqué dans le
milieu de la mode en effet tous les
vêtements sont parfaitement portable
jean charles de castelbajac rebond soir
dans ça
jean-charles
sérieusement
j'ai fait il vous met 30 et et où cette
semaine parce que c'est vrai que depuis
votre séparation avec mareva galanter on
voyait moins dans la presse vous êtes
revenu à votre vrai métier il faut dire
c'était donc pas compagnon d'une miss
france votre vrai métier non mais jamais
été compagnon d'unifrance à marée basse
et eu d'abord une comédienne chanteuse
miss france a été une étape voilà way et
on est restés très amis et c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait par me jean
charles vous êtes depuis 40 ans l'un des
plus grands créateurs de mode en france
et dans le monde vous avez habiller des
plus grandes stars de farrah fawcett à
lady gaga même le pape jean paul 2
absolument que l'allié 1st désormais
alors le diable s'habille en prada le
pape en castelbajac donc jésus ou celles
à la halle aux vêtements
saisis donc jésus
prévu où jésus c'était au début de ma
carrière j'avais fait grand scandale à
18 ans parce que j'avais déposé le nom
de jésus oui et j'ai fait à ce moment là
c'était mon époque très rock'n'roll une
collection de jeans qui s'appelait jésus
on s'en souvient très bien on avait
affiché face au vatican heureusement il
avait oublié lorsqu'on a demandé d'
habiller le saint-père des affiches avec
le derrière de pâtes cleveland et de
donna jordan où il y avait écrit qui
m'aime me suive jésus de toute la fois
très anticlérical et très pro kanak la
1ère fois alors après vos débuts vous
avez utilisé des éponges de serpillière
des toiles cirées d'appropriation ce qui
m'a intéressé c'est est de traduire tous
les souvenirs d'enfance mes souvenirs de
pension cet art du petit rien la corde
élastique éléments de réponse la bande
velpeau mais ma première veste a été
surtout
l'autodafé de ma couverture
pensionnaires dont j'ai fait une veste
voilà voilà ensuite j'ai eu la période
de pop art sa c 4 août il l'a alors vous
présenter une collection très
géométriques très simple retour à mes
bases voilà on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
voilà trente ans et et 2015 jean charles
de castelbajac
alors jean charles vous est il faut le
dire je crois hétérosexuels oui ça on
peut l'affirmer j'imagine que dans le
milieu de la mode ça n'a pas dû être
facile à faire accepter thierry j'ai
toujours été différent au début on
faisait croire si tu es fan de madonna
vous disiez manche où mon chou comme ça
pour jamais tout faire accepter par les
autres en tous les cas vous oubliez lady
gaga oui j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
clip téléphone aurait travaillé
récemment sur le sait c'est très cool
quand même de sa part d'avoir un ami
hétéro ou non alors vous venez d'une
vieille famille mobilières qui a célébré
il ya vingt ans son millénaire
ne s'est pas notre musique
[Musique]
vous êtes parent avec monsieur tursac je
ne suis pas parent cursac mais si la
date est un gascon chandon sûrement vous
êtes shonali légion d'honneur commandeur
des arts et lettres
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
et ma plus belle récompense
ça restera quand même mareva galanter
non sans doute pourquoi pas sophie
thalmann elle préfère l'équitation je
crois
bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
alors maréval c'est fini mais rien n'est
jamais fini avant des marées basses pas
finie elle continue sa vie avec arthur
que oui avec quel droit vous avez pas un
pincement au coeur quand même quand vous
la croisez dans une soirée avec un autre
non honnêtement aux roms et non pas du
tout pas du tout syrie
iran thierry me fait ce coup là depuis
40 ans et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus